kader est absolument on le voit les sami
naceri vous allez me dire donc dans quel
ordre étaient les trois bandes-annonces
2 3 1 tab et deryk c zéro en dix huit
ans samy naceri piccoli ne dépend pas du
tout pas du tout et samy naceri jantes
way samy naceri est tout à fait capable
de rompre avec les bandes annonces de
ses filles et qu'est ce que c'est que
cette histoire un bien alors dites moi
un sami justement vous avez un bon
avocat quand même quand vous le savez
maintenant parce que c'est une même que
chirac
bien sûr c'est un monaco qui parce que
là la dernière fois franchement en juin
dernier vous étiez pas au mieux un
javier pris huit mois de prison avec
sursis 5000 euros d'amendé trois ans
d'annulation de permis bon salaire
beaucoup comme ça mais par rapport à ce
que vous avez fait c'est pas énorme ce
qu'il a fait aux îles à il est pourri
c'est pratiquement tué trois polonais
par de bagnolet mais alors si ce contrat
avec n'arrive pas je viens faire la
promo du dvd reconnaître des bandes
annonces
tu me fais mon curriculum vitae
judiciaire et tout ce que je propose
c'est ce que je te propose la vaisselle